so donald trump did a rally for arizona
republican candidate carrie lake on
friday evening he was hours late he was
dripping wet the entire speech it was
one of the absolute strangest speeches
that he gave and trump was booed at his
own rally and his reaction is so telling
about what matters to him we will get to
that let's go through some of these
clips again trump finally taking the
stage dripping wet barely audible at
moments his voice almost completely gone
and he one of the first claims trump
makes when he takes the stage is that
gas currently costs
nine
dollars per gallon when i was in office
yes gasoline have thing called gasoline
now nobody wants to even talk about it
was 1.87
and now it's five
six
seven and even in some places eight and
nine dollars a gallon
i love the people nodding in the
background as if they know that to be
true when it's obviously not true now
just about everything trump says about
gas prices is a lie one of the things
that trump said was that it was 187 when
he left it wasn't it was more like 220.
uh but gas prices are now down
dramatically in fact gas prices if you
look they peaked at 502
in mid june we are now about five and a
half closing in on six weeks of steady
declines down to about
428 or so a gallon the highest price in
the country on average is california at
574. the lowest is texas at 387 high but
not
super dramatic so just it it's all lies
trump then claims he finished the border
wall now this is funny because trump in
speeches says both that
if you if he gets the opportunity again
they're going to finish the border wall
and also that it's done illegal aliens
and gang members
and we built hundreds of miles of border
wall
in fact we completely finished our
original plan
despite two and a half years of democrat
inspired lawsuits now remember that the
plan was a border wall across the entire
us
mexico i mean i'm exhausted at this
point it was the whole border that was
the promise it was a first-term promise
and they added like 90 miles or
something like that trump also with his
continued delusions of grandeur claiming
that he saved merry christmas
remember i said we're going to save
christmas merry christmas we saved merry
christmas didn't we the department store
said don't buy if they don't have
merry christmas they were
told it's not good they want to get rid
of christopher columbus but more
importantly merry christmas but they say
merry christmas again don't they right a
whole different thing this is what i
call dumb red meat it's an attempt to be
red meat but instead of being the type
of stuff we used to see like about
welfare queens or whatever the case may
be it's just
dumb red meat um this was maybe one of
the most fascinating moments in the
speech trump and deus endor hinduist
endorsed this guy named blake masters
and the crowd booed and then what's
fascinating is trump goes you still like
me right and at the end of the day
that's what he cares about and a highly
respected man just endorsed by me today
future congressman for the second
district eli crane oh sorry this isn't
the blake masters moment this is the eli
crane moment okay still debut now
thank you
[Applause]
but you like me right okay
and that is a throwaway line but that's
the truth trump doesn't really care
whether he helps these people that he
endorses beyond how it reflects on him
if it's a win in his endorsement record
that he touts great
if you don't even like the person he
endorses and you don't vote for them
fine as long as you still like trump
trump then pulling out the victim card
saying no one no one has been through
what he's been through and as a post
office post uh post-presidency president
he's supposed to be having a great life
now not embroiled in all sorts of
scandals
who has been through anything like what
i've been through seriously
who
certainly no politician and
definitely no president a president
leaves office and
it's supposed to be a wonderful life
and all this while i was doing so much
as
president including the most secure
border in american history isn't it guys
just truly truly a victim
uh many of you also noticed that
they
during trump's speech it sort of seemed
like they swapped out the black people
that are on stage behind trump this is
like a tried and true staple of trump
speeches which is trump has almost no
black supporters i mean when you look at
the numbers almost no black supporters
but there's always black supporters up
on the stage behind trump it was notable
that there was a particular black guy
over trump's right shoulder at the start
of the speech and he did seem to be
swapped out with a different uh trump
supporting black guy i can't tell you
any more about it other than a bunch of
you noticed it and wrote to me about it
trump then denied the claim made by
cassidy hutchinson under oath to the
january 6 committee that he threw
ketchup at the wall
then they had me throwing food
throwing food in the white house i don't
throw food in the water i don't throw
food anywhere
i eat the food which is a problem i'd
probably be better off if i threw it
yeah i think the next time i should
throw it i won't eat it i'll be much
better off but i'm throwing food in the
wedding and remember everybody who was
going to come forward and under oath
dispute the claims of cassidy hutchinson
they haven't shown up and we're going to
talk about that tomorrow trump referring
to his son don jr as just a good kid
who's getting a bad rap don jr is a 44
year old adult with multiple children
but he's a good kid trump says think of
it to tell you how bad a person is right
so
adam schiff is a sleazeball everybody
knows not a dumb person by the way you
know we're not dealing with dummies but
he's a sleazeball you take a look
perfect watermelon head you know
and he's angry with biden because he was
supposed to get a job in the
administration and they didn't want them
but he goes up he's a smart guy goes up
to the microphones thank you thank you
very much this is a sad day for america
donald trump jr
has a relationship with russia
and the you know they know it's a fake
deal because they're they're more fake
than adam schiff and they're all going
click click click now think of this just
speak to this here's a young guy don
jr's a good kid
isn't that something i mean
it's kafka-esque um a staple of trump
speeches now is this anti-trans line
that no teacher should be allowed to
teach transgender we still don't know
what that means
and no teacher should ever be allowed
to teach
transgender to our children without
parental concern right you need a
permission slip to be taught transgender
i still don't even know what that means
another classic of trump rallies is when
trump calls you up to speak if you're
the person he's endorsing
you had better be quick
and mostly praise trump if you start
talking about policy when trump calls
you up you see trump immediately glaze
over these cultists know exactly how to
do it right well thank you mr president
i really just wanted to thank you
for saving this country
do you agree with me did president trump
literally save this country right
[Music]
well thank you so there it is he knows
exactly the right way to do it uh
complete and total cult then carrie lake
came up another trump and dorsey
um and she just straight up refers to
trump as superman
this is how
you have to placate the petulant child
or he will flip out and get bored
and i think arizona is your favorite
state you don't have to say but i think
arizona is his favorite state
president trump taught us how to fight
and i took a few notes
that's why i go after the fake news
because he showed us how to do it he
gave us the game plan and he showed us
exactly how to stand up and fight and
republicans need to fight back
now you'll notice trump's already kind
aboard
now listen
we can't sit back and wait for superman
to come
come in and rescue us right now
we can't wait for superman to rescue us
right now
we have to stand up we've got to vote
we've got to get active we have to make
sure we tell our friends to vote
and we have to be
running for office running for school
board each and every one of us has to
get involved use your god given gifts
and get involved to save this country
now i want to say for the record
for the record i do believe that
superman is coming back and hopefully
he's coming back soon
there you go uh so there is the i mean
this is a complete and total cult and
then last thing trump
goes on a weird tangent about executing
drug dealers and that finally gets the
crowd cheering
we're going to stop this scourge it's
time to get by the way it's the word is
scourge and he continues to not be able
to say
brutally tough on the dealers
traffickers at the narco terrorist
cartels who are stealing millions and
millions of lives we lose 200 and 250
000 lives a year
and i heard a statistic that each drug
dealer will kill during a period of 10
to 15 years
anywhere from 20 to 50 people and the
bigger ones kill hundreds and hundreds
of people
what when i was with president xi of
china
i said you have a drug problem
rather naively
no
no why do you ask he couldn't understand
the question
i said why don't you have a drug prep
well we have quick trial
what's a quick trial
quick trial is if they are dealing drugs
they have a quick trial
and they're executed immediately
we don't have a
quick trial system crowd likes that
and i see it all the time and i have a
lot of friends they're wonderful people
they all want to be on the committees
and we call them blue ribbon committees
headed up by
nice people wonderful people okay so
anyway another one of these bizarre
events the crowd very very bored after
waiting hours for a late trump and uh
the cult continues and unfortunately he
gets the crowds and if he decides to run
for 2024 he has a very very good shot so
let's go from the rally to the turning
point usa event on the following day
one of our sponsors is better help the
customized online therapy service that
offers video phone and live chat with
your therapist you don't even have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to you fill out a questionnaire to help
assess your specific needs and then
you're matched with a licensed therapist
in under 48 hours you can schedule
secure video and phone sessions you can
exchange unlimited messages with your
therapist and you can request a new
therapist at any time for any reason
at no charge talking to a therapist
doesn't mean there's something wrong
with you it means you're doing something
for yourself and for your wellness you
get your car serviced you work out you
see the doctor to prevent physical
illness and disease
therapy is the same thing anyone can
benefit from it i think it's very
important join the two million plus
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with better help get ten
percent off your first month at
betterhelp.com pacman the link is down
below